Everything is Awesome according to the
Democrats the party of pronouns is
spiking the football on the Biden
presidency even as Americans cry uncle
the president likes to say it is never a
good bet to bet against the American
people and he is right
but what I want to say today is it is
never a good bet it's bet against Joe
Biden and this team never ever a good
bet I'm saying to people the Joe Biden
uh has earned another term now you can
use whatever trained metaphor you want
anyone you want but get on the Joe Biden
Express now because we are not stopping
except to the restroom sorry Chuck looks
like the Biden Express is going off the
rail 73 percent of Americans say they
are dissatisfied with how things are
going in the country but the New York
Times bearded nitwit Paul Krugman thinks
people are too stupid to understand
their own finances quote will Americans
even notice an improving economy end
quote well Jesse 7 out of 10 people
that's um can you 70 seconds yeah yeah
seventy percent
when I heard that I thought wow that's
really low
right where are the 30 percent that
think he's doing a great job because I
haven't met them and as you know I'm a
man of the people you live downtown I'm
sure you've run into a few of those
people you know I live amongst Biden no
there's nobody even Biden supporters
don't support him all right well I'll
find some if you give me a mic Biden is
in deeper trouble than everybody
realizes these investigations are going
to be nasty you got House Republicans
you have a special counsel you have
Hunter blowing up and it's not looking
good also the far left on the March you
have Liz Warren taking shots at Kamala
Harris and then Bernie's got a book out
and he's going on tour that means he
might run for president the economy they
say is going into a light recession and
Vladimir Putin's about to throw a half a
million soldiers at Ukraine during the
Spring fighting season and then you guys
skipped his physical and covered it up
and lastly his legislative agenda is
grinding to a dead stop in Congress
I'm not seeing great stuff on the
horizon maybe these guys are taking
pills I don't know about oh
Dana I feel I feel like their slogan is
it could have been worse right well
that's constant right they so they would
love to run against President Trump
every day just to say but like not as
bad as that in their minds
um this is also very interesting timing
you have a change in the chief of staff
Ron claim um look give him his due he he
won in the tug of war of President Biden
wanting to be very empathetic and Clay
wanting to tell everybody that
everything is great everything is fine
and you know what Afghanistan was the
biggest airlift in history and you will
like this economy you will love it it's
going to be great and you find out that
the train that they're talking about
stops at inflation station and it's a
runaway situation we have recession on
the horizon maybe it's not going to be
that bad so I do think Republicans need
to be thinking about this right because
they're the the Democrats are trying to
say that any economic woe that you have
right now goes back to the 2017 Trump
tax cuts it's nonsense but that's what
they're saying they're forgetting the
spending of covet under both presidents
they're forgetting the inflation
reduction act even though they that was
the inflation promotion act and also the
environmental inflation act I do think
though that this change in the chief of
staff you could see a messaging change
as well because now you have all these
investigations like he's talking about
and you have a situation with a
republican house so I don't think you're
going to hear all happy talk except for
on Tuesday when the president gives a
state of the union then after that maybe
not Geraldo what do you see in this
conflict between what they're saying and
the reality around them
well I I don't see the reality is quite
the Gap uh the the reality guy quite as
profoundly as you as you lay it out I I
don't think there's going to be a
recession a meaningful recession I think
that Afghanistan in a few months will be
regarded as thank God we're not still
stuck there uh and I think that when you
see James Clyburn there uh the South
Carolina congresswoman he gave the
nomination to Joe Biden right there the
the renomination to Joe Biden and that's
it the rest is just going to be noise
Joe Biden's going to be running for
reelection and in my opinion he will be
running against Donald Trump because
Donald Trump is very difficult to beat
and uh if you look at any survey of the
internal Republican numbers he's the
candidate it's going to be a rematch two
Old-Timers and maybe I'm the only one
that can like translate for them oh man
it's going to be would you speak
Old-Timers Alzheimer's a debate stage is
going to smell of relief factor which by
the way really works
of nature is one of them that doesn't
stink there's some advertising they said
it doesn't stink that's their logo it
doesn't stinks okay you want to know
what I think this is what I think I
think they really have to get themselves
all hyped up to come out and say you
know what there's so much enthusiasm in
this country it's wonderful and there's
not going to be a recession and all that
and they're all though you you know
whether you think it or not look I'm not
an economist I don't know but what I do
know is that when 81 of people think the
state of our Union is dysfunctional and
they're dissatisfied with it up from 71
two years ago and you know a sizable
majority rate economic conditions
negatively 80 percent that people who
make something like what is it a hundred
thousand dollars a year are living
paycheck to paycheck and that's 64
percent of Americans you can call it a
good day or you can call it a recession
they don't care what you call it right
eggs are too much gas is too much he can
say he brought Biden can say he brought
the prices of gas down but it's still
higher than when Trump was there and
everybody who was in the fossil fuel
business knows that everything is going
to stay high because we've got to start
buying everything else from other
countries and in the end no matter how
energetic they are we're still in a mess
and they know it and the Republicans and
I have to say this I was very impressed
with Kevin McCarthy yesterday when he
came out of that meeting with the
president and they said what did you
talk about he said I'm not going to tell
you what we talked about he was
respecting that communication and that
conversation but even more than that he
talked about the possibility of actual
cooperation and every American if you
felt like I did was like oh my God maybe
we can come together and if they don't
come out with something like Dobbs that
that was really what jackpoted Us in
terms of the midterms then maybe we will
do well and Americans will vote the way
they feel let's come together okay let's
go come by yeah come on Jesse all
together all right well I want to Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now